[Music]
PT's social study your quick catch up on
what's the labs are posting online
Catherine zeta-jones is total closet
goals the 47 year old actress posted
that video to Instagram over the weekend
showing off her incredible wardrobe to
tone test
Daphne odds flaunted her bikini bod on
the gram but later had to shut down
internet trolls leaving negative
comments the chu co-hosts wrote in part
quote I get how hard it is to feel good
in our skin I'm not perfect I have not
reached all my goals I still see all my
flaws first the progress is everything
and one positive feeling the gates
another Lady Gaga also took to social
media to address haters body shaming her
appearance during her epic Super Bowl
halftime show hosting a performance pic
along with the caption I'm proud of my
body and you should be proud of yours
too I could give you a million reasons
why you don't need to cater to anyone or
anything to succeed bu and be
relentlessly you we didn't feel prepared
to be parents the first time around
Jessa Duggar's Seewald shared the first
photo of her adorable new bundle of joy
the reality star and her husband Ben
welcomed their second child another boy
on Monday February 6 Jamie Lynn Spears
husband Jamie Watson took to Instagram
to thank fans for their support after 8
year old Maddie was in a major ATV
accident over the weekend posting this
pic of a sweatshirt that reads
believe in miracles along with the
caption Maddie is doing better and
better
[Music]
you